we bring in broadcasting royalty he's
Vin Scully the Dodgers broadcaster Jonas
on the show then good morning thanks for
joining us I was wondering about this
when we were gonna have you on what was
Plan B if you didn't become a
broadcaster well I believe I was going
to be a sports writer I had done the
following things I wrote a column for
the high school paper I then wrote a
column I went to Fordham University and
Fordham prep so I wrote a column called
looking me looking them over for the
college paper and that column had been
originally written by Jon Carin and then
Arthur Daley so I was in big-league
bootstraps right then trying to keep up
so that's I think what it would have
been perhaps a writer was there a moment
that just it kind of took you to another
level or it just entered you and never
left you where you said okay now I know
that that's what I want to do well what
I really wanted to do believe it or not
I was about 8 years old and we had a big
old radio in the living room 4-legged
with a crosspiece for support underneath
it and as an 8 year old I would get a
pillow I would crawl under the radio so
that my head was directly under the
loudspeaker and I would listen to
college football games on Saturday and I
had no idea who was playing I mean it
could be Michigan Ohio State or
Tennessee Alabama but it didn't mean
anything except I loved the roar of the
crowd and it's pretty much of a cliche
but the roar came out of that
loudspeaker like water out of a shower
head and I just got goosebumps and so
each week I would just lay there
thinking oh my gosh I'd love to be there
I'd love to be there then I began to be
intrigued with the announcers voice
maybe it was oh I don't know Ted Husing
or
stern or red barber or someone like that
and that was my path I thought you know
what combining the roar of the crowd and
to be there broadcasting that would be
it for me
and so that really was the beginning but
being a good listener helped you be a
good broadcaster I assume so
I've always again getting back to that
eight year old I have always loved the
roar of the crowd so that anytime
there's a play that unfolds number one I
try to be as accurate as possible number
I to do it as quickly as possible to get
out of the way for the roar of the crowd
and for those few seconds while I sit in
the booth I'm eight I'm in love with the
roar of the crowd toughest sport to call
well I think baseball really for I
believe the listener of a baseball game
or a viewer of a baseball game probably
knows a lot more about baseball than the
average football fan or the average
golfer or tennis player or whatever
because most people have played some
kind of a game with a ball I mean it
could be softball or baseball or it
could be as a kid growing up in the
streets of New York with a broom handle
and a tennis ball but I think most
people have been exposed and therefore
know a little bit more now I'm only
guessing but that's my feeling when
you're also calling the sport sometimes
your voice will be accommodating to that
support you did the Masters so are you
announcing differently with your voice
and then you would when you called
Dwight Clark sketch in candlestick oh
well of course you get right back to the
roar of the crowd that's the the biggest
thing about golf the most exciting
moment in golf is deadly quiet and I can
remember sitting
oh just to give you an idea I'm at 18
and Tom Weiskopf and Johnny Miller come
to the 18th their one shot behind Jack
Nicklaus they need birdies each one has
a birdie putt that's pretty makable and
the crowd you could actually hear a bird
in the tree I mean it was deadly silent
so what I did was I said very simply
they each need a birdie a par they will
lose to Nicklaus and I've said enough
and I moved the microphone behind my
head so I wouldn't say anything else and
shatter the moment because in those
instances is the silence that is so
exciting
talking to Ben Scully the Dodger
announcer as he will wrap up 80 years is
that what it's gonna be then well no not
exactly
I'm wrapping up 67 years doing
play-by-play for the Brooklyn Dodgers
and the LA Dodgers the 80 if you don't
mind me telling you it's kind of an
interesting story do we have time for
this sure oh okay yeah I was about eight
and a half years old
not quite nine and I was coming home
from grammar school walking the 20
blocks or whatever from my school and it
was October the 2nd 1936 and I walked by
a Chinese Laundry and in the window was
the line score of the World Series game
played that day and I stopped and looked
and the Yankees beat the Giants Oh
helped me 18 to 4 doesn't sound like a
World Series game and as a small child
when I looked at it my first thought was
oh those poor Giants so since the Polo
Grounds was only 20 blocks from my
school and the fact that we got out at
2:30 and the games began at 3:15 plus
the fact I was a member of the Police
Athletic League and the Catholic youth
organization
I could go to games free Monday through
Friday so I became a rabid Giants fans
my last game will be October the 2nd
2016 with the giant exactly 80 years to
the day when I first saw that World
Series game and fell in love with
baseball that's awesome
do you have a plan can you plan your
final broadcast I don't want to
I've never planned I really don't want
to make a big deal out of it because
it's already been made a big deal out of
it I'm I'm appreciative but I'm also
embarrassed I've never wanted to get out
in front of the game and for a long time
I was able to keep that game center
stage and I was the voice off in the
wings now that it's my last year
considering all the years that I did
it's become a kind of a big deal and it
is embarrassing most appreciative but
embarrassing so I don't want to break
down on the air I don't want to get
overly emotional and I might so I'm
going to try very hard to be as simple
as possible and let it go at that
the I can tell you this much there was a
there's a letter that I wrote which will
be given out to all the fans I think
starting Friday the 23rd and it's a
letter of dedication to the fans and
then there's something else I did which
will be I think quite a shock quite a
surprise but I'm not saying what that is
but that will occur on my last day at
Dodger Stadium on the 25th of September
then the last game will be in San
Francisco and I would just like to do
that game and that would be that but you
understand your family member I mean
this this is hard for the for the
listeners that mean it I can't imagine
how emotional be for them when they're
listening and then let alone you
trying to wrap up 67 years and say
thanks I mean that gonna be pretty
emotional
pretty emotional game there October 2nd
VIN I I would think so I'm relying on
the Giants and the Dodgers to making it
a good game an exciting game so I can
kind of do what I love to do keep the
game out in front and I'll kind of hide
behind it I hope how tough is it to no
matter what the Dodgers do in the
postseason that you won't be
broadcasting those games well you know
Dan I gave it some thought naturally and
I didn't want to sound like I'm saying
goodbye and Grand Opera where you say
goodbye I'm going I have to go did I
tell you I'm going I didn't want to do
that and I thought you know I'm gonna
say goodbye in Los Angeles at Dodger
Stadium and then I'm going to say
goodbye up in San Francisco for the end
of it I didn't want to do all those and
then come back and do radio in the
postseason and and don't misunderstand
me I'm not putting radio down I just
mean that I will have said goodbye twice
and I think that's enough then if you
could hold on I'd love to have some I
have some more questions for you I got a
lot of questions for you so when we come
back I'm gonna ask you about the moment
you think you captured in perfect style
and what would Jackie Robinson think
about these protests before the anthems
that we find in in sports certainly in
football we'll continue with a great Vin
Scully and we'll do so after this Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you